وبما انه دخلنا في سيره تويتر وال الماسك
لازم نتكلم عن احدث اخباره فهو من وقت ما
استلمت تويتر وهو متحفنا صراحه بالتغريدات
والردود والقرارات واليوم الموضوع مختلف
ال الماسك فجاه ادهش متابعينه وبتغيير
اسمه على تويتر اسامه نفسه مستر تويتي
يعني السيد تويتر اللي بيسال ليه اختار
هذا الاسم بالتحديد فقدر انه ماسك بوجه
الدعوه قضائيه رفعها عليه مستثمرين تسلم
من 2000 2018 بسبب تغريد تتكلم فيها عن
خصخصه شركه تسلا وتم اتهامه بعدها باطلاع
في السوق وكانت بدايه الجلسات او بدات
جلسات المحاكمه في القضيه يوم الاثنين و
خلال الجلسه محمل مستثمرين طلعت منه كده
غلت لسان او هي مقصوده او كان قصده يتمسخر
ما احنا عارفين طبعا يعني الله اعلم
بالنوايا المهم المحامي قال الماسك مستر
تويت
تويت ولا تفكروا انه كثير قاعده او
التغيير هذا مؤقت لا لانه يبدو انه الم
وورط نفسه فهو من بعد ما غير اسمه غير همم
غرد انه هو غير اسمه الى مستر تويت وتويتر
مو راضي يسمح له الان يرجع لي اسمه
الحقيقي مره ثانيه
[موسيقى]